il ya de plus en plus d'études qui
montrent que la récession qui est causé
par la pandémie de kobe 19 creuse les
inégalités notamment entre les hommes et
les femmes
selon le fonds monétaire international
l'impact est telle que cette crise
pourrait anéantir une partie des gains
qui ont été faits depuis 30 ans
notamment au chapitre de l'équité
salariale
le fmi note d'ailleurs que le phénomène
est présente partout aussi bien dans les
pays riches que dans ceux en
développement
on va essayer de me comprendre tout ça
avec monde publiait zélés professeure
adjointe à l'institut national de la
recherche scientifique merci d'être là
madame publiait ce bonjour merci à vous
de l'invitation
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer
comment on arrive à dire que les femmes
sont touchés de manière disproportionnée
par la crise actuelle ben en fait il ya
différentes
il ya différents de mesures de pour
faire état de l'emploi chez les hommes
et chez les femmes
une mesure qui est utilisé beaucoup dans
l' enquête de statistique canada banque
natio là pardon
l' enquête sur la population active de
statistique canada
notre le taux d'emploi ça représente la
proportion des adultes ou enfin des gens
de 15 ans et plus qui sont en emploi et
donc si on regarde ce tout leur est si
on regarde le changement par exemple au
mois de juin par rapport à ce qui était
observé en février avant la pandémie
chez les hommes on est à 92 % de ce qui
était observé avant la pandémie
j'ai un corner rattraper le retard que
vous voulez ben en partie pour
complètement dont 92% de rattrape mans
si on veut et chez les femmes c'est
seulement 89 pour ça donc on voit que
les gains ont été moins les pertes
avaient été plus important c'est les
gains sont moins au rendez vous
également
est-ce qu'on explique sa madame publié
par le type d'emploi que pelé femmes
comparativement aux hommes entre autres
oui c'est vraiment c'est certain que ça
fait partie de l'explication les emplois
qui ont été très très touché par la
pandémie sont des emplois qui sont à
prédominance féminine dans plusieurs
décors donc on pense aux secteurs par
exemple du commerce de détail
tout ce qui est le spi qualité également
c'est des emplois où il ya beaucoup de
contacts sociaux et qui ont vécu des
pertes massives d'emplois et ce sont des
secteurs on doit le rappeler pour qui la
reprise va être peut-être plus lente que
d'autres et ça c'est une réalité là
le fait que les femmes soient plus
touché qu'on observe chez nous
évidemment mais on observe aussi un
petit peu partout est ce qui est dans
d'autres pays du monde où l'impact est
encore plus marquée oui enfin je pense
en trop c'est certain qu'ils aient pays
où les ressources économiques sont moins
abondantes
les impacts sont sont plus marquées dans
le sens où les pertes d'emploi font plus
mal peuvent donner lieu à des phénomènes
vraiment de pauvreté d'ailleurs le fmi
dans son intervention reste hymne et que
les taux de pauvreté parmi les femmes
allaient augmenter énormément le haut
niveau au niveau mondial
c'est une préoccupation et twitter ont
parlé de la nature des emplois on
parlait de commerce de détail le secteur
touristique par exemple ce sont des
secteurs dans lesquels c'est encore plus
difficile de faire du télétravail alors
plus difficile pour les femmes d'avoir
accès quand même à un revenu exactement
c'était vraiment là je pense la plus
grosse partie de l'histoire s'est
décidée secteur où c'est tout simplement
pas possible qu'on doit servir quelqu'un
comme on le voit actuellement sur les
images ça c'est pas malheureusement
télétravail et même quand c'est possible
de faire du télétravail une des
observations c'est que c'est plus
compliqué évidemment au niveau de la
répartition des tâches dans le couple
quand deux travail qu'on a des enfants
souvent ce qu'on a observé
statistiquement c'est c'est la femme qui
met de côté un peu plus ses tâches en
lien avec le travail
oui c'est tout le temps par exemple au
québec une étude de ruth rose en 2016
qui estimait que les femmes à chaque
jour passent deux points deux heures de
temps de travail parental
chez les hommes c'est 0.9 donc qu'ici on
est assis sur une semaine de chute
7jours ça fait vraiment une grosse
différence 9 heures de différence entre
les hommes et les femmes
et je mentionne aussi que oui c'est
inégal dans le couple mais il ya
beaucoup de séparation a commencé de
gens qui sont seuls et à ce niveau là
aussi les femmes sont beaucoup plus
susceptibles que les hommes d'avoir la
charge unique d'un enfant ou d'avoir
davantage de temps parental dans les
unions qui sont en garde partagée
donc pour ces femmes-là vraiment là le
travail parental est extraordinaire et
bien sûr on le sait c'est quelque chose
qui a été complètement modifiée durant
la pandémie avec la fermeture des écoles
des garderies
bon évidemment l'impact de tout ça s'est
fait sentir pendant le confinement se
fait encore sentir maintenant parce que
les emplois ont peu été retrouvé par les
femmes mais est-ce qu'on pourrait amener
les impacts longtemps saisir difficulté
d'avancement de carrière que ce sera
plus long pour gagner des revenus par
exemple on pourrait le sentir parement
une génération c'est possible je suis
tout ce qui est possible mais je pense
qu'une façon de voir peut-être les
impacts à long terme c'est de constater
que certaines raisons pour lesquelles ce
sont les femmes qui qui qui ont qui
renoncent un petit peu plus à l'emploi
soit soit pour des raisons chômage mais
aussi pour prendre en charge les tâches
parentales ca t1 entre dans le fait que
les femmes ont des plus bas revenus
donc c'est sûr qu'on comprend quand les
coupes doivent choisir qui on priorise
et bien les femmes du fait de moindres
revenus ont moins de pouvoir de
négociation donc on voit qu'en fait les
autres les impacts des inégalités
précédente se font sentir actuellement
et donc on peut imaginer que c'est une
roue qui tourne et d'un amplifiant
phénomène
ça va ça va continuer quels fonds
monétaire international on en parlait
qui demandent justement au gouvernement
d'agir d'intervenir de quelle manière on
peut atténuer le choc pour les femmes
c'est certain quand on voit que les
services de garde notamment les écoles
c'est extrêmement important pour
permettre aux femmes de pouvoir
travailler après ce bon moi je suis pas
du tout une spécialiste la santé alors
je m'avance pas sûr si c'est la bonne
les réouvertures c'est vraiment ce qu'on
a ce dont on a besoin
mais sinon c'est certain qu'on peut
imaginer des programmes de soutien et
peut-être particulièrement pour les
familles avec enfants qui peuvent venir
compenser certaines des pertes de madame
publiait merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
merci à vous